kopfloser Wille ruhige Art dominantes Haar
Bassam islamischer Fundamentalist Geschmack
populistischer und feministischer In-Game-Gegenstand
cialis Organisation Ära Identität auf
Suhana Anakin auf dust2 gemeingeistige
Minderheit ger Böen ihre Alpha-Gesellschaft,
wo einige andere Konishi
pollito okay Francis Fukuyama kopflose
Aufklärung
vielen Dank, ja  Verdammt noch mal,
der eisige Garten würde Angela Commons nicht sehen
Arkin verschleierte Rechnung
Thermalwissenschaftler Schwestern in der
Sowjetunion Sie folgen ihrer Berliner Mauer Er
ist hier drin Bill de da Telefon auf beschlagnahmtem Aktin
16 Liter Diesel Agnes Authority macht
jeden Tag in der Türkei
Bassam Saddam schätzt, dass
der Begriff „Geschichte“
in einem sehr spezifischen Sinne verwendet wurde. Es war
derselbe Sinn, den die Marxisten verwendeten. Sie
glaubten auch, dass es ein Ende der
Geschichte gibt. Geschichte bedeutete einen Prozess der
Entwicklung oder Modernisierung, wo immer Sie
hingehen  durch verschiedene Stadien der
Zivilisation und das Argument war das,
was am Ende dieses Prozesses stand  s
das Ende der Geschichte und der Marxist sagte,
das Ende der Geschichte sei der Kommunismus gewesen,
der das Endstadium der menschlichen Entwicklung war,
und meine Beobachtung im Jahr 1989, als
ich den ursprünglichen Artikel schrieb, war das Ende der
Geschichte mit einem Fragezeichen am Ende,
dass es so war  Es sieht nicht so aus, als würden
wir jemals zum Kommunismus gelangen, dass das,
was Marx als bürgerliche Demokratie bezeichnet
, die letzte Stufe sein würde, weil
es anscheinend keine
höhere Zivilisationsstufe zu geben schien, zu der wir
uns entwickeln würden, und so war es  das
Argument, und ich glaube, wir befanden uns in diesem Moment
mitten in einer großen
Demokratisierungswelle, die
durch den Fall der Berliner
Mauer, wie Sie sagten, gekrönt wurde, und das war
das Argument,
dass die Demokratie nicht universell war, aber sie
war  Der Trend und dies war die
höchste Entwicklungsstufe, die ein
2ds in Saipan Talent erreicht hatte, ist der
Wunsch des anderen, ihm zu verweigern
mir ist gemeinsam, dass
einige Städte eine gespenstische Ordnung haben, als
unsere SATs für jede, weil ich vorher gelehrt habe, dass
ich Gartenhäuser TZ TZ
b VAR-Höhe gut sehen kann, also gingen wir durch das,
was der Politikwissenschaftler Samuel
Huntington die dritte Welle der
Demokratie nannte,
also dazwischen  1970 und ungefähr 2010 oder so stieg die
Zahl der Demokratien in der
Welt von 35 auf etwa
155, also gab es eine
wirklich große Welle der Demokratie auf
der ganzen Welt in Asien, Afrika und
Lateinamerika, diese Periode ist meiner Meinung nach eindeutig erreicht
ein Ende und wir befinden uns jetzt in einer
umgekehrten Welle, in der es jetzt zunehmende
Bedrohungen für die Demokratie gibt, also
Bedrohungen aus autoritären Ländern
wie Russland und China und auch durch eine
steigende Welle des Populismus, und daher denke ich, dass
der Fortschritt zur Demokratie
unterbrochen wurde und vorbei ist  Natürlich ist die große
Frage für die Zukunft, ob
dies ein dauerhafter Rückschlag ist oder ob
dies einfach ein Sie wissen, wie die
Börse nach oben geht und manchmal
geht es dann doch wieder nach unten  n der langfristige Trend
ist positiv, die Nähe war
verrückt, dass M okatee DBA 11 das ist es.
Ich denke, dass ein Teil davon das Ergebnis
der Globalisierung ist, die in der Welt aufgetreten ist,
also ist es nicht nur so, dass die Demokratie
eine bestimmte Menge gut gemacht hat  liberaler Ideen
setzte sich auf der ganzen Welt die Idee durch,
dass wir für den Handel offen sein sollten für
Investitionen für Bewegungen von Menschen, und
in den letzten 40 Jahren gab es wirklich eine
unglaubliche Explosion dieser Art
von Verbindung zwischen Gesellschaften
, die viele Länder hervorgebracht hat  reicher,
aber nicht alle haben davon profitiert,
und deshalb denke ich, dass in vielen entwickelten
Gesellschaften in vielen reichen Gesellschaften viele Menschen aus
der Arbeiterklasse gesehen haben, wie ihre
Arbeitsplätze nach Asien in andere Teile der Welt verlagert wurden,
sie haben einen Zustrom von
Ausländern gesehen  wurde Ihnen bekannt gemacht
durch die Flüchtlingskrise im Jahr 2015
, die Europa heimgesucht hat,
und all dies hat meines Erachtens eine Gegenreaktion ausgelöst,
eine populistische Gegenreaktion gegen
diesen Trend  ards zunehmende Offenheit
in der Welt, also denke ich, dass dies der
unmittelbare Auslöser für diese Entwicklungen ist. Die
gesundeste Achse der Forschung und Entwicklung war oft 57 Führer
heist Polizeimonster in einer
Ostpremiere über Cha Felicia war unsere Optik
und Studentenmilizen
so rückgängig gemacht cool - war wirklich eine Angst für
Identität als vamoosed Nun
, das ist richtig Ich denke, dass die
konventionelle Erklärung eine wirtschaftliche ist
, aber ich denke, dass wirtschaftlicher Verlust
häufig in kulturellen Begriffen interpretiert wird,
also wenn ich meinen Job verliere
oder wenn ich weniger Einkommen als mein
Vater verdiene, sehe ich das so  ein
Statusverlust und ich denke, dass Sie das
interpretieren können, indem Sie
Ausländern die Schuld geben, indem Sie es der ausländischen
Konkurrenz oder Einwanderern ins
Land geben, die Ihnen die Arbeitsplätze wegnehmen, oder Sie
wissen, dass die Grundlage des Wohlfahrtsstaates untergraben wird,
so denke ich, sehen Sie das
Was ich ziemlich interessant finde,
ist, dass wir in den 2000er Jahren
sowohl in Europa als auch in den Vereinigten Staaten ein paar große wirtschaftliche Misserfolge hatten,
also gab es den
großen Subprime-Mor  tgage Krise in den USA
2008 und dann war da die
Eurokrise hier in Europa, diese wurden
in dem Sinne von Großbanken von
Sie kennen die Eliten konstruiert, und es hat den einfachen
Menschen geschadet, und Sie würden normalerweise erwarten,
dass dies zu einem Anstieg des
Linkspopulismus führen würde, so die Parteien  der Linken
sollten daraus Kapital schlagen und gut
abschneiden, und stattdessen sahen Sie in
den Vereinigten Staaten den Aufstieg der Tea Party und
in Europa all dieser Anti-Immigranten-
Ante-
Peon-Union-Parteien, die eine
viel nationalistischere, schmalere
Linie verfolgen  und ich denke, das ist ein Beweis
dafür, dass die kulturelle
Dimension wirklich wichtig ist, diese Identitätsdimension
und nicht nur die wirtschaftliche
Ungleichheit, die wir heute
sehen  Unglaubensschaden
und geglaubte Motorplatte
Vivendi warf über Schöpfung namens
Extremis ich bin gerade jetzt auf Aquino
runtergeflogen und die Beleidigung auf unsere
Gedanken ein Lebenszeichen wer  kann jeden
dedizierten Dämon heiß haben, wie vermisst, das sind die
drei am besten zugänglichen
Sowjets, also ist Thumos ein griechisches Wort, das sich
auf die universelle menschliche Eigenschaft bezieht,
dass wir wollen, dass die Leute uns respektieren. Wir sind
nicht nur an materiellen Gütern
wie Essen und Trinken interessiert  und Geld wollen wir auch
Respekt von unseren
Mitmenschen und eigentlich sind wir bereit,
um des Respekts willen auf wirtschaftliche Vorteile zu verzichten
und ich denke, dass dies einer
der großen Treiber der Politik ist, hat eigentlich der
große Philosoph Hegel das
Ganze gesagt  Der historische Prozess wurde von der
Forderung nach Respekt vorangetrieben, dass sich Sklaven
zur Zeit der Französischen Revolution gegen ihre Herren erhoben,
weil die Sklaven nicht den
grundlegenden Respekt oder die Würde erhielten, die
sie ihrer Meinung nach als Menschen verdienten
und so  Ich denke, dies ist einer der großen
Treiber, insbesondere in der modernen
Politik, diese Forderung nach Würde und
Respekt durch bestimmte Gruppen ist ein
glänzendes Oberteil. Oh, sie neckt sie  Ich kann sehen, ich
habe nicht, nur ich kann nicht, und erwähnen Sie als Sohn
Kegel PDF nette Tante Politiker die meisten von
uns Indien, bevor Sie weiterlesen, beginnen
Sie mit der sozialen Augustine, dass dies auch Podesta VISTA tut,
dort gut geküsst, es
gibt sicherlich eine Menge Studien, die
zeigen  dass es eine biologische Grundlage
dafür gibt, also gibt es einen Neurotransmitter
Serotonin, den
das Gehirn auslässt. Sie wissen, wenn Sie
Respektgefühle haben, wissen Sie, und das gilt
sogar für andere Primaten
wie Schimpansen. Wenn Sie den
Status eines Alpha-Männchens erreichen, haben Sie einen erhöhten
Serotoninspiegel  Dafür gibt es einen biologischen
Grund, aber ich denke, dass es
kulturell eine sehr spezifische
moderne Form dieser Forderung nach Würde gibt,
die wir meines Erachtens, wie Sie wissen,
gerade im vergangenen Jahr den 500.
Jahrestag der protestantischen
Reformation und in vielerlei Hinsicht die
Reformation und Luthers Schrift gefeiert haben
insbesondere Sasser ttans
modernes Verständnis dieser Forderung nach
Respekt, denn was er sagte, ist das,
was einen Ch ausmacht  ristianischer Gläubiger ist in Gottes
Augen nicht die äußere Person, es ist der
innere Glaube, den man nicht sehen kann, der innere
Glaube, in dem er sich nicht in Ritualen zeigt,
und so weiter, es ist im Grunde
der innere Glaube eines Menschen, und
das ist es, was Wert hat und  das ist die
moderne Ansicht von Respekt, dass wir diese
innere Quelle der Würde haben, die
Außenwelt erkennt diese Würde nicht an
und muss sich anpassen, sie
muss kommen und uns anerkennen, und tatsächlich
ist das nach der
Reformation passiert, die Luther völlig
untergraben hat  Grundlage für das mittelalterliche
Christentum, indem Sie die Kirche angreifen, und
Sie wissen, indem Sie sagen, dass es eine
andere Grundlage für den Glauben gibt, da wir
in etwas passen, das ist Jesus Peterson
, auf dem ich nicht stehen
kann  Ich verstecke mich in einem klaren
und ruhigen Inneren der wütenden Bevölkerung, und
Trump bricht es phänomenal auf oder
unter Himmels Annehmlichkeiten frisst mich nicht
zum Fahrzeug als feministische II-Sho  uld
sein Fahrzeug oder liefern die schwarzen Leben
Materie die Unbestimmtheit von Schwartzberg
Verhaftung Vivian bekam auch eine wirklich süße und
fundamentalistische Massage innerhalb des Islam und
startete Jungfrauen ist unser neuester Kinderstar Eva
Hall auf dem Silizium Podesta interessant
gut, also ist es zunächst einmal sehr wichtig, das
zu sagen  Nicht alle dieser
erwähnten Bewegungen sind von gleicher moralischer Statur, so dass
sie vielleicht von einem ähnlichen
psychologischen Bedürfnis nach Respekt und
Würde angetrieben werden, aber ich denke, Sie wissen, dass Sie wissen, dass
wir das Aufkommen
dieser Ich-Bewegung in den USA und anderen Ländern gesehen haben
Unter den Frauen, die versuchen, sich
gegen sexuelle Übergriffe und sexuelle
Belästigung zu wehren, und wie Sie sagten, ist das Leben der Schwarzen
wichtig, und diese beiden
reagieren auf echte und Richter
Sie kennen diese Verunglimpfung Russlands
nach dem Zusammenbruch der Sowjetunion,
aber die Art und Weise, wie er dies zum Ausdruck bringt, widersetzt sich
diesem Groll  indem er versucht,
dann alle seine Nachbarn wie die
Ukraine und Georgien und die baltischen
Staaten usw. zu dominieren, und moralisch ist dies
nicht dasselbe, wie Sie wissen, dass ein
Afroamerikaner gegen
Polizeibrutalität vorgeht, aber ich denke, dass es
psychologisch einen ähnlichen Grund
gibt  dass die Menschen das Gefühl haben, dass sie
diesen inneren Wert haben, der nicht
respektiert wird, und die Forderung und Politik ist
, ihm Respekt zu verschaffen - Ivan
Sushil, okay, sie war ein anständiges Image und
der Amigo jeder Partei will und wird
in aktuellen Daten nicht durch Abnutzung zerstört
Dass ich vom Feminismus vakant sein soll,
gehört dem symbolisierten Ende in Tucson und
Abhava, die es definitiv genossen, sich
mit einer Gruppe und Identität zu verbinden. Wir beharrten
darauf, dass ich dachte, dass im Voraus schläft,
dass diese Person ein Elch ist,
im Missionsbereich, wie sie und ich uns
bewegen können  in unserer kachel ich na kabhi bahu
mestizen kommen copan denke jetzt ist es übertrieben
gefragt wirkung gut ich denke es gibt
eine reihe von gründen dafür die
prämisse einer liberalen soc  iety ist, dass wir alle
Individuen sind, und ich denke, die früheste
Manifestation dessen, was wir Identitätspolitik nennen,
war eine Forderung nach persönlicher
Befreiung. Wenn Sie sich die Hippie-
Bewegung in der San Francisco Bay Area
in den 1960er Jahren ansehen, wissen Sie,
dass es Leute gab, die Gesellschaft sagten  Das hindert mich
daran, mein volles Potenzial auszuschöpfen,
und ich muss mich befreien, aber ich
denke, das Problem ist, dass Menschen, wenn
sie in sich selbst graben,
oft keine einzigartige Person
finden, was sie finden, ist eine Art
Vakuum und ein Verlangen  für die Verbindung zu
anderen Menschen, und so wird das wirkliche Ich, das in mir lebt,
plötzlich zu meiner
Verbindung, meiner Gemeinschaft mit anderen
Menschen, und das ist es, was meiner
Meinung nach diese Gruppennatur der Identität vorangetrieben hat.
Wissen Sie, zum Beispiel hatten wir diesen großen
Aufschwung in Katalanisch  Nationalismus Nach
dem Sturz von Francisco Franco waren
viele Katalanen froh, dass
sie in einem demokratischen Spanien lebten,
aber für viele Menschen war das nicht genug
, dass sie es taten  Sie hatten das Gefühl, dass sie
mehr Inhalt für ihre Identität brauchten,
sie hatten eine gemeinsame Sprache und eine Geschichte
, die sich von der Spaniens unterschied,
und ich denke, das ist der Ursprung dieses
Siebenden Strebens nach einer separaten
Anerkennung Kataloniens als Wissenschaftler,
und glauben Sie mir  In einem Titel erhöhte das einzige heilige
Feuer das Herz zum
Auswendiglernen von Chavez Vista, weil es nur
Staub war, der voreingenommen war, war fertig
und dann Süßigkeiten, wie weit der Himmel mit einigen von ihnen gefüttert wurde, wie
ikonisch die Homies
sind, also ist es sehr ironisch, denke ich,
die Ursprünge  Ich denke, dass
Menschen als Mitglieder von Gruppen
richtig behandelt werden, also haben Sie eine Person, die schwarz ist,
oder Sie kennen Muslime oder Frauen, und die
äußere Gesellschaft stereotypisiert sie, dass
sie als Mitglieder der Gruppe passen, sie
achten nicht auf ihre Individualität  Sie wissen
, das nennen wir Vorurteile,
Rassenvorurteile, oder Sie kennen sexuelle
Diskriminierung, geschlechtsspezifische Diskriminierung, und
ich denke, dass diese Gruppen und die Menschen
in ihnen ag zurückdrängen  Anstatt dieser
Gruppenidentifikation, aber während des Prozesses
wissen sie, dass sie gekommen sind, um diese Gruppe zu sehen,
wissen Sie, dass sie sich selbst zum
Team dieser Gruppe erheben wollen, und sie sagen also,
ja, wir haben eine separate
Identität, wir sind nicht nur wie alle
anderen  Die Gesellschaft, wir haben unsere eigene
Erfahrung, also Afroamerikaner, Sie wissen ganz
genau, dass Sie eine Lebenserfahrung im
Umgang mit weißem Rassismus haben. Frauen haben eine
ganz andere Erfahrung als Männer. Ich
glaube, Sie sehen in der feministischen Bewegung, dass
ein Teil von ihr wollte, dass Frauen
gleich behandelt werden  zu Männern in Bezug auf
Bezahlung, Beförderungen und Jobmöglichkeiten,
aber es gibt einen anderen Aspekt des Feminismus
, der sagt, nein, eigentlich sind Frauen nicht nur
Männer, Sie wissen, dass Männer tatsächlich all diese
Probleme haben, sie sind aggressiv, sie wissen nicht
, wie sie kooperieren sollen, sie wissen es nicht
Sie kennen die Tugenden, die die Frauen haben, und
deshalb wissen Sie, dass die vollste
Manifestation unserer Identität
eigentlich darin besteht, nicht nur wie Männer mit
all ihren Lastern zu sein, die wir sein wollen, wissen Sie
Wir wollen etwas Eigenständiges sein, und deshalb
denke ich, dass dies Teil der Dynamik ist
, die zu dieser Rückkehr der Biologie in
gewissem Sinne geführt hat, wo die Art und Weise, wie
man geboren wird, die Art und Weise bestimmt, wie man
sich in der Politik verhält, denkt und handelt,
wenn es schnell geht  Sukhram ist nicht einfach, diese
sind sehr da ist unsere Versuchung nicht
H diese Aufgabe es überlebte die Stone
Trumps und Präsident Fiat verletzen die
politische Korrektheit Phillotson Viola
achten auf Sativa werden behindert sogar gefundene
lose Ignoranz hilft eher unser ist ist V
aus ist nicht zu Hause  ist dies H Nehmen Sie
nicht an, da zu stehen.
Authentizität wird im
westlichen Denken seit langem
kultiviert  Sinn ist
falsch, es ist eine falsche Auferlegung von Regeln, dass
Sie wissen, dass die frühesten Menschen
isoliert und glückliche Individuen waren, und
sie werden unglücklich durch die Tatsache, dass
sie lebendig sind  ng in einer Gesellschaft,
die sie mit all diesen
restriktiven Regeln umgibt und dass die wertvolle
Person diese innere Person ist,
die authentische innere Person, der
wir uns oft nicht einmal bewusst sind, dass sie
in uns lebt, und so denke ich wirklich
seit Russos Zeit und und so
Ich denke, das spiegelt sich auch in anderen
wichtigen Denkern wie Kant wider, der sagte,
dass es unsere moralische Handlungsfähigkeit in uns ist
, die uns als Menschen Wert verleiht,
also ist es dieses innere Selbst, das
authentisch ist, das ein Wert ist, und das
entwickelt sich im 19. Jahrhundert zu einem
Glaube an die innere Kreativität und den
Wert der inneren Person, und das ist
etwas, als das westliche Denken
uns schon eine ganze
Weile begleitet hat.
Tut mir leid, Schwester Anna, es war eine gute
Frauenfrage  Wütende
Kommunisten helfen, Falcon Savita, seinen
Sargon, zu sehen, Albert tat, Lincoln Patel hat
uns nach Unzucht betrogen, sogar Schaden
cinq sous vide kickdown mateesah
Identität Eds poli  tic Vedas bittere Haut
und Angst bis zur höchsten Osmond sogar
Figur Minda geschärfte Sinne und
Savita das ist, dass Suki gemeinsam damit
Theresa Identität seine Politik die Verbindung
bekannt noch Süden nach gut Ich denke, dass
es gerade eine allgemeine
Neuinterpretation der Ungleichheit auf der
Linken gegeben hat  Früher war es eine allgemeine
wirtschaftliche Kategorie. Wenn Sie sich also die Politik des 20. Jahrhunderts ansehen, waren
kommunistische und sozialistische
Parteien alle dafür, der
Arbeiterklasse zu helfen, die während des größten Teils des
20. Jahrhunderts weiß war, Sie kennen
Menschen der dominierenden ethnischen Gruppe in der
Gesellschaft, aber  Marginalisierung wurde zunehmend
als Eigentum dieser
spezifisch diskriminierten Minderheitengruppen angesehen
, und diese Parteien begannen, den
Kontakt zu den weißen Wählern zu verlieren,
die der Kern ihrer Unterstützung waren, wie Sie wissen,
in den frühen Jahren gab es auch, denke ich
, eine Adoption von a  Art von
ideologischem Multikulturalismus, der besagt,
dass Aktionsgleichheit
nicht Gleichheit von
Individuen bedeutet, sondern Gleichheit o  f-
Gruppen, und wir werden Sie wissen, versuchen
, das Ansehen dieser kulturellen
Gruppen als Gruppe zu erhöhen, selbst wenn diese Gruppe
Einzelpersonen
unter ihren Mitgliedern auf eine Weise diskriminiert
, die mit einer wahrhaft liberalen Gesellschaft nicht vereinbar ist
Was an diesem Punkt geschah, war, dass viele
der weißen Wähler, Mitglieder der dominanten
ethnischen Gruppe, zu glauben begannen, dass Sie die
Agenda dieser Partei kennen, die nicht meine Agenda ist, und
so gab es
sowohl in Europa als auch in den Vereinigten Staaten große
Abweichungen von der Linken  -Parteien gegenüber
diesen rechtsgerichteten Gruppen, die als
stärker identitätsschützend angesehen werden, wissen Sie,
dass diese ältere Klasse von
Wählern der Arbeiterklasse, so dass die Demokratische
Partei
in den letzten dreißig Jahren viele Wähler der Arbeiterklasse an die Republikaner verloren hat
Jahren war
die Kommunistische Partei in Frankreich, die Sie
kennen, eine solide proletarische Partei,
jetzt wählen viele dieser Leute den
Front National, so dass ähnliche
Dinge in ganz E vor sich gegangen sind
Europäische Mystik in der Höhe und wütende
Sätze bei Salomon heiße Ehrlichkeit, ich sage ein
Beißer, sie konzentriert sich auf Tiamo 21-Klasse in
Austin, sie ist einfach ein Kollege Lincoln,
Teilzeit-Anti-Diffamierung, ein Stock-
Meeresfrüchte-ISM in den Schlagzeilen, es ist jetzt
die Ergebnisrate, die es hat  gute
Muslime sind gut. Ich denke, ich denke, das
stimmt. Ich denke, es gibt auch ein
kulturelles Phänomen, bei dem
es politisch korrekt wurde
, die Rechte von Minderheiten, die
Rechte von Frauen, die Rechte von Schwulen und
Lesben zu betonen
Interesse von Ihnen wissen grundlegende soziale
Gerechtigkeit, aber es bedeutete in
gewissem Sinne eine Herabstufung der
Aufmerksamkeit, die Ihnen geschenkt wird, ältere
Menschen kennen, die nicht
älter sind, sondern ältere Gruppen
, die die dominierenden Mitglieder
der Gesellschaft waren  In den Vereinigten Staaten zum
Beispiel ist es wahr, dass Sie in
Hollywood oder in den beiden dominierenden Parteien
oder in der Elitekultur wissen, dass weiße
Arbeiter nicht das
Ziel ihrer Angriffe waren  obwohl
sie Arbeitsplätze durch Outsourcing verloren haben, und
Sie kennen ausländische Konkurrenz, und ich glaube,
viele dieser Leute waren sehr
verärgert darüber, dass sie
vom System vergessen wurden, und das, glaube ich, dann
den Groll antreibt, der sie
zur Stimmabgabe geführt hat  Für die Opposition von Donald Trump
übergibt Aquino direkt an CSR Halbwindsor
Heu Casera oft hinter uns im neuen
SRC Ascheschadstoff Indien Ein Copan auf dem
System ist in Ordnung fertig gut Ich denke
, wenn Sie an den Nahen Osten denken
, ist das der oder der Balkan, das sind diese
sind Regionen, in denen Identitätspolitik
die ganze Politik ist, Sie wissen schon, Syrien,
Irak, Libyen, Afghanistan, Somalia,
das sind Gesellschaften, die eigentlich
auseinandergefallen sind, weil sie kein
übergreifendes Gefühl nationaler Identität haben,
sie bestehen aus Identitätsgruppen
, aus denen sie bestehen  definiert durch ethnische Zugehörigkeit durch
Religion durch Sekte durch Stamm
und niemand hat ein Gefühl der Loyalität gegenüber einer
höheren politischen Einheit, die es ihm
erlaubt, auch nur dort zu bleiben  Zusammen
als Single wissen Sie, dass es in den meisten
europäischen Gesellschaften und in den Vereinigten
Staaten Minderheiten gegeben hat, aber
Sie wissen, dass es Bemühungen gibt,
sie in die herrschenden Gesellschaften zu integrieren, damit
sie nicht dauerhafte Minderheiten
bleiben, sondern Sie bleiben  Kennen Sie Identitätsgruppen
, die ihre eigene Sprache sprechen und
ihre eigenen Bräuche haben, leben Sie parallel zu
der Sie kennen die dominierende Gesellschaft oder
zumindest war das die Hoffnung in den
Vereinigten Staaten. Ich denke, das ist
gelungener als in Europa, aber ich denke
, das ist das  hier besteht die gefahr, wenn man
migrantengemeinschaften hat, die nicht
ausreichend integriert sind, die sich nicht als
vollwertige mitglieder der
dominierenden gesellschaft fühlen und
dann getrennt leben und dass dies
etwas ist, das sich bis in
die zweite dritte generation fortsetzt mr.  Medina
hat nicht einmal Häuser für
große Leidenschaft Energie verloren, aber ist in nicht sonal
und besuchte DC DC fremd zum nächsten über
Passivität Chefarchivarführer haben
die Saudis nicht diktiert und einen Thomas
Jackson gegessen, der schwanger bleibt. Ich fühle mich
so kotzend  verletztes Klicken, also kamen mein Großvater
und die Seite meines Vaters
1905 aus Japan in die Vereinigten Staaten, also war es vor 110
Jahren, vor mehr als hundert, vor zehn
Jahren wollte er nicht in
die japanische Armee eingezogen werden, um gegen Russland und die Russen zu kämpfen.
Japanischer Krieg Er gründete einen
Eisenwarenladen Mein Vater wuchs in Los
Angeles auf Er war sehr amerikanisiert Er
sprach ein wenig Japanisch, aber
wirklich nicht sehr gut Ich spreche überhaupt kein Japanisch
Ich bin in New York City aufgewachsen, davon gab es
nie viel
Als ich in den 1950er und 60er Jahren dort aufwuchs, sah
ich mich immer als
Amerikaner, nicht als asiatischer Amerikaner, nicht
als japanischer Amerikaner, und ich würde sagen, dass
dies auch die Erfahrung meines Vaters war,
dass wir nicht behandelt wurden  Sie wissen
besonders anders als andere
Arten von Amerikanern, nur weil
wir rassisch anders waren, wenn
Zivilisten navneet, wenn sie hausiert wurden, wer mich angerufen hatte
, als er mit der Arbeit anfing, zu dem ich gekommen war, also
ja, also würden die Leute das fragen würden
, aber Sie kennen meine Antwort immer
Warum ich aus Chicago kam oder wiederkam,
ich wurde geboren und aber die Sache ist,
dass es in Amerika meiner Meinung nach schon seit geraumer Zeit möglich ist
, diese Antwort zu geben. Sie
wissen, dass das, was es bedeutet,
Amerikaner zu sein, wirklich nicht durch
ethnische Zugehörigkeit definiert wird  definiert durch du weißt durch
deinen Glauben an bestimmte amerikanische
Werte eigentlich durch die Art, wie du Englisch sprichst,
wenn du Englisch mit einem
Akzent sprichst, weißt du, dass du angesehen bist,
ist ein bisschen außerhalb der Gemeinschaft,
aber wenn du, wenn du  hast keinen Akzent
und du verhältst dich wie ein Amerikaner. Ich denke,
du wirst als akzeptiert
und das ist es eigentlich, was
mich an der aktuellen Situation in den
Vereinigten Staaten beunruhigt, weil du jetzt
den Aufstieg von White Nat siehst  Ionalisten, die
tatsächlich rückwärts gehen, Sie wissen
, dass sie versuchen,
das Land zurück in ein ethnisches
Verständnis zu ziehen, dass es bedeutet, ein
echter Amerikaner zu sein, ein weißer Amerikaner zu sein,
und ich denke, das wäre ein
schrecklicher Verlust, wenn Sie wissen, ob
sie dabei erfolgreich sind, da seine
Intensität bei einem Auftritt kein politischer Trump ist.
Sehen Sie, Hablaba-Kommentare sind politisierend.
Geben Sie Austrittswunde-Kefir
Es gibt einige Bars, die nach
neun sechs leben - es ist von Saddam Hussein
Ich bin auf Tom Ford und Rockland
County Vendee auf der Amish-Distanz gegangen, aber
einmal geerbte schlechte endemische Herzen und
Gewürze sind von
Politikern Peralta und Think Tanks und
aus Spaß lange verboten  Dragon on the Bush Senior
Bus Hutton als Rocky gab in einigen anständigen
Politiker-Casinos so
gut, dass ich denke, vieles davon war nur eine
Reaktion auf Dinge, die in der realen Welt passiert sind,
also in den 2000er Jahren  Ich denke, die
größten Ereignisse waren der Irakkrieg, den
ich für einen großen außenpolitischen Fehler halte.
Ich begann zu sehen, dass Sie es vor
dem Krieg wissen, und es stellte sich tatsächlich als
ein viel größerer Fehler heraus, als ich
erwartet hatte, und das andere war die
Finanzkrise  im Jahr 2008 und
beide basierten auf bestimmten
konservativen Ideen, die erste
basierte auf dieser Idee, dass die Vereinigten
Staaten ihre militärische Macht nutzen könnten,
um die Politik einer kulturell
sehr unterschiedlichen Region umzugestalten, und die zweite
basierte auf einer Art Übertreibung  Liberalismus
, der sagte, dass Märkte ohne Regulierung
für sich selbst sorgen würden, und
beide haben sich meiner Meinung nach als
zutiefst falsch herausgestellt, und das andere,
was meiner Meinung nach der Hintergrund
dafür ist, ist, dass aufgrund dieser sehr
liberalen Politik einfach
viel passiert ist  wachsende Ungleichheit,
besonders in Großbritannien in den Vereinigten
Staaten, von denen Sie wissen, dass sie
diese sogenannte neoliberale Revolution
mit Ronald Reagan und Margar begonnen haben  et Thatcher darauf
drängten, den Sozialschutz abzubauen,
Sie wissen schon, die Sozialpolitik zu definanzieren, um einen
Teil davon zu deregulieren, war gerechtfertigt,
aber vieles davon ging viel zu weit und
das Ergebnis war ein massiver Anstieg der
Ungleichheit in den letzten 3040 Jahren,
und Sie wissen, dass ich das denke  Die Welt hat sich verändert,
und deshalb meine Politik des Wandels. Ich
denke, ich war ein guter Nischenführer der Dogness.
Er hat zwei und Damas in einem
arktischen Salben vor Yahoo gepostet und folgt
aus seiner eigenen Begabung, also habe ich Steve,
ja, ich denke, dass es einen
gab  ein guter Grund für
Reaganismus und Thatcherismus, weil ich
denke, dass in den 1980er Jahren ein Großteil der
Wohlfahrtsstaatspolitik vieler fortgeschrittener
Länder unbezahlbar geworden war, sie
hatten zu Hyper- und Hyperinflation geführt, Sie
wissen, stagnierendes Wachstum, es gab zu viel
Regulierung in vielen Bereichen,
also ich ja  Ich denke, dass
es damals eine gute Idee war, einige dieser verkrusteten staatlichen Richtlinien zu lockern, aber
Sie wissen, dass wir in der öffentlichen Politik
diese Pendelausschläge hatten, wo Sie wissen, dass Sie es
tun  Nach der Weltwirtschaftskrise hatten wir eine zu
liberale Politik, also fingen sie an
, Dinge zu regulieren, die in den 1970er Jahren zu einer Stagnation führten,
also haben wir dereguliert, und dann
gehen wir jedes Mal ein bisschen zu weit,
und das erzeugt, Sie wissen schon, eine
Gegenwelle  Wie wir darüber nachdenken,
wie wir mit der Wirtschaft umgehen sollen und so
weiter, es ist immer ein Sie kennen einen neuen
Identitätsslogan  Sie Nancy
Identitäten und all den Schaden, wie er für die
Einführung nicht Sonali es im Detail und
kunstvolle nicht jetzt Ställe räumte die Idee
und hören Legierung nicht geworden, also hielt ich
tatsächlich einen Vortrag über Latsis
Vortrag in Genf
zurück in ich glaube 2010 oder 11 weiter  dieses Sub
in einem europäischen Kontext, weil sich der
europäische Kontext
aufgrund der Europäischen Union vom amerikanischen unterscheidet,
so dass die Gründer der
Europäischen Union in Europa die nationale Identität gewissermaßen
als den Feind der beiden betrachteten
Weltkriege waren aus aggressivem
Ethno-Nationalismus entstanden, und die Europäische Union war
in gewisser Weise dazu bestimmt, die
Mitgliedsstaatsidentitäten Frankreichs,
Großbritanniens oder Deutschlands durch eine Art
europäische
paneuropäische Identität zu
ersetzen  Jürgen Habermas, Sie kennen
den deutschen Philosophen, und ich denke, es
war in gewisser Weise eine sehr edle Idee, dass es
der Europäischen Union gelungen ist,
die
Möglichkeit eines künftigen Krieges zwischen
Deutschland und Frankreich zum Beispiel zu verringern, aber das
einzige, was sie nicht geschafft hat
tatsächlich eine echte europäische
Identität geschaffen wird, die die
Identitäten der einzelnen
Länder ersetzen würde, aus denen die Europäische Union besteht,
und ich denke, die Eurokrise war ein großartiger
Beweis dafür, dass dies
ein Fehlschlag war, also nach der Krise Griechen und
Deutsche, denke ich  waren sich
ihrer Unterschiede viel bewusster als
ihrer Gemeinsamkeiten, wissen Sie, also waren die
Deutschen bereit, c zu nehmen  Sie gehören zu den
schwächeren Mitgliedern der deutschen Gesellschaft mit einem
Sozialstaat, aber sie waren nicht bereit
, die Griechen als Teil einer großen
Familie zu sehen, von der sie wissen, dass sie eine
Verantwortung für Sie haben,
für die sie sich gesorgt haben, und so denke ich, dass Sie in
Europa immer noch sind  eine integrierende Identität
brauchen, wäre es schön, wenn Sie diesen
starken Sinn für einen europäischen Aspekt hätten. Bis auf
Weiteres bleiben wir bei der Person hängen,
Sie kennen nationale Identitäten,
und das ist wichtig, weil Sie
Menschen integrieren müssen, die Sie gemeinsam haben
müssen  Glaube an die grundlegenden
Institutionen und die Legitimität der
grundlegenden Institutionen Ihrer Demokratie, wenn
Sie einen Erfolg
für die Demokratie haben wollen, ist unser Ostern so bestimmt
und wurde nett zu Disney
Sie können
Masse für faschistische Parteien beherbergen. Maz Kanata
steht hoch für die Sparren der Partei. Es
waren Befehle zum Verlassen von Stahl
Er drinnen unter gut, es hängt davon ab,
was Sie unter Lichtkultur verstehen. Der
Begriff Light Cool Tour wurde also von
einem Syrer erfunden, einem Professor, der
in Syrien geboren wurde und dann den
größten Teil seines Lebens in Deutschland
Bassam tibi und sein Verständnis
davon unterrichtete  war eine Kultur, die, wie Sie wissen, nicht
durch Religion oder durch Sie wissen eine
sehr tiefe Reihe kultureller Gewohnheiten definiert wurde, sondern
wirklich eine Art Treue zu diesen
Prinzipien der Aufklärung war, also ging es
über die einfache Treue zur Verfassung hinaus, von der
Sie wissen, dass
es mehr Substanz gibt  es, aber es
beinhaltete einen Glauben an
westliche Werte, die meiner Meinung nach der modernen Demokratie zugrunde liegen,
und in diesem Sinne
denke ich, dass Sie wissen, dass das wertvoll
ist
eine Gesellschaft
zusammen ihre tieferen
Traditionen mit Ritualen
mit Feiertagen mit Essen mit vielen
Dingen und da gerät man in
Schwierigkeiten, weil nicht e  Jeder, den Sie kennen,
teilt Ismen in einigen dieser Gewohnheiten
mm-hmm Kenzi blitzt auf und benimmt sich in
Stiefeln  Jetzt im Ernst, sie kommt
konkret, war es besser als wir,
also denke ich, die Antwort ist ziemlich klar,
also wollen die Familien in vielen muslimischen Gemeinden
, dass ihre Töchter
jemanden heiraten, den sie gutheißen, und
so oft wird die Tochter
nach Marokko oder nach Marokko zurückgeschickt  Pakistan oder Sie wissen,
wo die Familie herkommt und
einer arrangierten Ehe ausgesetzt
ist. Ich denke, es gibt andere Probleme, die mit Antisemitismus zu tun haben
über die
Gesellschaft wissen, aber beim
Beispiel der Tochter bleiben Ich denke,
dass dies zwar eine
in der muslimischen Welt weithin akzeptierte kulturelle Praxis
ist, aber mit der liberalen
Demokratie nicht vereinbar ist  tischen Prinzipien in einer liberalen
Demokratie denken wir, dass alle Menschen,
einschließlich aller Frauen, Entscheidungsträger sind, was bedeutet, dass
sie die Freiheit der Wahl bei den
wichtigsten Entscheidungen haben, die sie in
ihrem Leben treffen, insbesondere, wen
sie heiraten werden, und die Familie in einer
liberalen Demokratie sollte dies nicht tun  das
Recht haben, die Tochter dazu zu zwingen,
jemanden zu heiraten, den sie nicht heiraten will.
Das ist ein Beispiel, an das ich denke,
wo eine kulturelle Praxis die
Grenze überschreitet und beginnt
, ein grundlegendes zugrunde liegendes Prinzip
von Liberalen zu verletzen  Individualismus, von dem Sie
wissen, dass er die Grundlage unserer Art in der
Demokratie ist.
Ramdas, das ich erwähnen möchte - das
coole Zeug - zur Hölle, wenn Sie sich dumm fühlten oder der
Kapitän Sie spät anmachte, gab
diese Stimmung dem Multikulturalismus, oder es
hängt davon ab, wie Sie
Multikulturalismus so definieren  Eine Definition ist
nur eine empirische Beobachtung,
dass es viele Kulturen gibt, die in
Ihrer Gesellschaft koexistieren, aber es gibt eine Art
ideologische Version von Multiculturalis  m
, das besagt, dass alle Kulturen, einschließlich der
westlichen Kultur, gleichermaßen wertvoll sind und
gleichermaßen respektiert werden sollten, und dies hat
zu einigen Konsequenzen geführt, sodass
es eine und extreme Version von
Multikulturalismus gibt, die eigentlich antiwestlich ist
, wissen Sie, wo ihre Befürworter
sagen, dass keine westliche Kultur darauf basiert
Sklaverei, Kolonialismus, Rassismus, das ist die
Essenz der westlichen Kultur, und das ist
schlecht,
was ich denke, es ist nur eine
Art lächerliche Behauptung.
Ich meine, es ist in
gewisser Weise historisch korrekt, aber es ist auch sehr
unkorrekt, aber die andere Version davon ist meiner
Meinung nach problematisch  dass alle
Kulturen als Kulturen gleich behandelt werden müssen
, und ich denke, dass dies einfach
ein falsches Verständnis der
Grundprinzipien einer modernen Demokratie ist
Rechte der
kulturellen Gemeinschaften, unter denen sie leben,
und daher denke ich im eigentlichen Sinne
In der liberalen Demokratie müssen wir die
Rechte des Einzelnen schützen und nicht
unbedingt die Rechte kultureller
Gruppen. Wir machen Zugeständnissen an kulturelle
Gruppen, weil die Menschen auf unterschiedliche Weise leben wollen,
aber Sie kennen das
Beispiel der Tochter, die
nicht heiraten will  Sie wissen, dass in einer
arrangierten Ehe meiner
Meinung nach Grenzen für die Toleranz bestehen, die
Sie gegenüber bestimmten Arten
kultureller Praktiken haben können, da ein
Gespräch von Connie Sue mit Christine
ein Connie Sundaresh mit Andre ist
IMF auf eine ähnliche Art und Weise besitzt sie
Unterwäsche, eine Hündin Dean, sie wurde zu seiner
Identität und seiner nationalen Identitätsnische
, holte sich ein Herz, CEO und
integrierte Sonnenschein, der nach China und
Vicks Gesellschaft gehörte, holte den Arzt
London gleich zu einem befreundeten Onkel George, um
Abbasi zu fragen, aber in  König, um diesen Osman zu stoppen,
hat diese, es kommentiert diese Lungen
auf Dolly-Mission, Schwester Nonne, die in D
in diesem monatlichen Brunnen bestanden wurde, ich betrachte eigentlich
Integri  und Assimilation als sehr
ähnliche Arten von Begriffen. Ich denke, dass
es sicherlich Aufgabe der
herrschenden Kulturen ist, zu erkennen,
dass es andere Wege gibt,
Dinge zu tun, und andere, wie Sie wissen, dass es eine
Vielfalt in der Art und Weise gibt, wie Ihre Bürger
leben werden  und man muss diese
grundsätzlich tolerant und akzeptierend sein
, aber ich denke, es ist auch so,
dass eine moderne Demokratie ihre eigene
Kultur hat, sie hat eine bestimmte Kultur
, die mit
Toleranz,
Glauben an den Glauben des Einzelnen zu tun hat, und Sie
kennen grundlegende Gleichheit und  dass dies
kulturelle Werte sind, von denen ich denke, dass Sie
wissen, dass sie sehr schwer zu kompromittieren sind,
und daher kann es kein völlig
wechselseitiger Austausch sein, bei dem Sie wissen, dass Sie anfangen
, einige im Wesentlichen undemokratische
Werte zu akzeptieren, nur weil Sie wissen, dass Sie
versuchen möchten, den Menschen entgegenzukommen
in das Land kommen, das
sehr, sehr unterschiedliche Werte kennt von
denen, die Ihre Gesellschaft wirklich prägen, Sie
haben neue Körper Askaban  Java fuchsbau
häng an dilemmata - fick mich - Hairston
komm und DISA kombiniert ich meine cool -
wo ist er identität und Tom ist der
frosch übergroße frauen entweder haben ein
schnelleres herz der christ kommt
der rest von uns bestellt oba weichherzige
co-  Investieren Torito eine Waage auf Mana
Kollege bla bla bla Schuss für das
Verdienen außerhalb Fäustling wo ist Polly -
Luton Mark Lee Schloss ist gebrochen es wird
ungefähr bestrahlt und Details
politischer Multikritiker auf dem Lincoln
August war nicht auf die Höhe stolz
und mit mir Anu  Enki Minenschächte widerlegt, es
gibt gewisse Unterschiede, die
etwas erreichen können, wir müssen verstehen, was
für Kreaturen wir sind, um damit anzufangen,
es gibt viele unvernünftige Leute,
entweder viele beschäftigte Leute, es gibt
viele ungebildete Leute, wie
bringt man eine Nation zusammen?  so
machst du es symbolisch du machst es mit
symbolen du machst es mit rhetorik du
machst es indem du über deine geschichte sprichst und
sogar und vor allem kannst du dich nicht nur darauf
konzentrieren o  In den schlechten Dingen in deiner Geschichte
musst du in der Lage sein, die guten Dinge zu erzählen, auf die
die Leute stolz sein können,
die sie zusammenbringen, du musst
die ganze Seele einbeziehen, sozusagen die
lutonische Seele, nicht nur den rationalen Teil,
ja, CNN nicht  zerschlagen zwischen militär
ich unterschreibe ein formular für
vimana nicht sonali dann detektiv ja nun
das ist eine sache die man in der
schweiz hat die wir in den
vereinigten staaten nicht mehr haben aber nein ich glaube
martha lila hat recht die muss man haben
gebräuchliche Symbole, also haben wir letzte Woche in den
Vereinigten Staaten Thanksgiving gefeiert,
was meiner Meinung nach der
wichtigste Nationalfeiertag in den Vereinigten
Staaten ist. Es wurde absichtlich geschaffen, wissen Sie
, es gibt eine Thanksgiving-Geschichte
über die Pilger, die in die USA kommen, aber
es war wirklich formalisiert  als
Nationalfeiertag von Abraham Lincoln und Teil
seiner Absicht war, das
Land nach einem schrecklichen Bürgerkrieg zusammenzubringen, der
dazu geführt hatte, dass 600.000 Amerikaner auf
dem Schlachtfeld starben, und das denke ich Ihnen
Das ist in vielerlei Hinsicht gelungen, denn
das ist etwas, das eigentlich alle
Amerikaner teilen. Der Baseballsport wurde
eigentlich auch Ende des
19. Jahrhunderts neu geschaffen,
um die Südstaaten
nach dem Bürgerkrieg wieder in die Union einzugliedern,
weil man das Gefühl hatte
dass wir einen gemeinsamen Zeitvertreib brauchten, mit dem sich
alle Amerikaner identifizieren würden, und
Sie wissen, dass es zu einem einigenden
Symbol werden würde. In meinem Buch erwähnte ich diesen Film
Invictus über Südafrika Nelson
Mandela, den ersten Präsidenten, den ersten
schwarzen Präsidenten Südafrikas, um den sich
der Film dreht  seine Entscheidung, zu
versuchen, Schwarze in Südafrika dazu zu bringen,
die Springboks zu unterstützen, die
die Rugby-Nationalmannschaft waren, weil in
Südafrika unter der Apartheid die Schwarzen
Football oder Fußball spielten und die Weißen
Rugby spielten und die Rugbymannschaft größtenteils
weiß war, und das war ihm auch klar  Sie
brauchten diese gemeinsamen Symbole, und so
wollte er versuchen, Rugby zu
einem nationalen Sport-Ra zu machen  Es ist mehr als nur ein
Sport für die weißen Afrikaner, und
so denke ich, ist dies ein Beispiel dafür, wie
die visionären Führer
gemeinsame Symbole und eine gemeinsame Sportkultur schaffen
, die ein
Sangu verachtet  Ich war eine Art
Kunstaufgabe, die vom Nationalspiel gefressen wurde, als
ich ein Auge sah, das menschlich verneint wurde. Der
alte Andre überlebte, wir polieren
richtig und stauben Lewiston ab
Astana sagte
einmal, dass all die schönen Spionage-Linden-Zeichen
gut sind, also denke ich, dass das Problem für mich ist,
dass die doppelte Staatsbürgerschaft etwas
ist, das für bestimmte
Personen, die sehr kosmopolitisch sind, von großer Bequemlichkeit ist.
Sie wissen, dass sie umherziehen, vielleicht kommt
ihre Frau aus einem anderen
Land  oder ihr Ehemann oder sie sind
ausgewandert oder so etwas, aber
es scheint mir, dass es ein echtes
Problem schafft, weil nicht alle Länder
wirklich daran glauben  die gleichen Prinzipien, ist
es nicht so sehr ein Problem, wenn die
beiden Länder beide gute Demokratien sind
und Sie wissen, dass beide eine Reihe gemeinsamer
Werte haben, aber in einigen Fällen wissen Sie
, dass dies nicht der Fall ist, und wenn Sie
Loyalität gegenüber einem Land haben, ist dies nicht der Fall
unmöglich von dr.  Kai, was für ein Gastgeberland
, also ja, das Beispiel, das ich
in dem Buch gegeben habe, war die Türkei, die unter Präsident Air Dewan
zu einem zunehmend autoritären Land geworden ist,
und
Sie wissen, dass er ausdrücklich
türkische Bürger in Deutschland angegriffen hat, um nicht
für Politiker zu stimmen, von denen sie dachten
wäre das Beste für Deutschland, aber die Politiker,
es wäre das Beste für die Türkei, und ich denke
, das ist ein Beispiel für eine geteilte Loyalität
, wissen Sie, ich denke, wenn Sie ein deutscher
Staatsbürger sind, sollten Sie darüber nachdenken, was das
Beste für Deutschland ist, und das ist
der Grund  Ich mag nicht, dass Sie die
Idee der doppelten Staatsbürgerschaft kennen, offensichtlich
wird es viel problematischer, wenn die Möglichkeit eines Krieges besteht,
weil Sie sich dann
wirklich entscheiden müssen, auf welcher Seite Sie stehen,
aber selbst kurz vor Krieg denke ich, dass es
ein It's a It's ist  Ein Problem für Sie wissen,
dass Länder, die wirklich unterschiedliche
Werte haben, kein Video haben, aber er ist eine Frage von
Hong Kuen und Tata, er Shanti McCarthy oder
irgendeiner Zustimmung, all das war ein heißes Design für
diese Identitäten  r lose Dinge zu
schwierig ein gewalttätiger sogar exponieren Knopf und
der Alec in der Tat der Baumeister von
allem Sturm durch besitzt Juarez im Jahr 2015
und die Kuchenfüllung einer Susan
hier ist Immunitätsjunge nach der
Balkanroute auf der Halbzeit Mia will die
Außenseite des Builds von der mexikanisch-asiatischen
Art  Zur Art und Weise, wie Sir
MC im Ausland die Kontrolle über
Fremde zurückerlangt, bin ich reine Heimmode, aber Isis
schießt Beton gut, ich denke, und dies
ist ein schwieriges Thema, darüber zu sprechen,
weil ich nicht mit Donald Trump identifiziert werden möchte,
weil er sagte  Dinge
, die diesen ähneln, aber ich denke,
dass man keine Demokratie haben kann, wenn
man nicht wirklich definieren kann, wer das Volk
ist, und man kann nicht definieren, wer das Volk
ist, wenn man nicht tatsächlich seine eigenen Grenzen kontrollieren kann,
also wird es sehr
problematisch  Als Menschen
illegal in Ihr Land eingereist sind, ist meine persönliche
Einstellung jetzt, dass Einwanderung
notwendig ist und für die meisten Gesellschaften eine gute Sache ist,
zumindest das Wirtschaftswachstum, denke ich
, die kulturelle Div  ersität ist gut für
Gesellschaften, aber wenn es
keine Grenzen gibt und insbesondere wenn
die Zahl der Menschen, die hinzukommen, die
Fähigkeit des Landes übersteigt, sie aufzunehmen
und sie letztendlich zu integrieren
oder zu assimilieren, dann denke ich, dass
Sie  Wir haben ein Problem mit unseren Adern - Chanel
Gate und Sufi haben zugehört und unsere Konzepte,
Alicia Creeks, verfeinern Ihren Teil, und
was auch immer ich getan habe, tut es, ja, aber die
Sache ist, dass es eine sehr
kompliziertere Sichtweise auf diese Art
von Problem gibt, ja, das ist
richtig humanitär  Deshalb ist es zu schade,
dass man jeden mitnehmen kann, aber Sie wissen
ehrlich, wenn Sie sich die
Demografie der Welt ansehen, gibt es eine Menge Leute
, die
in reiche Länder wollen, die Sie kennen, nicht nur jetzt,
sondern in den kommenden Generationen, und die
Frage ist  Können Sie weiterhin
lebensfähige, Sie wissen, entwickelte Gesellschaften haben, wenn
Sie nicht tatsächlich versuchen, diesen
Prozess auf eine Ihnen bekannte Geschwindigkeit zu kontrollieren, mit der
Sie tatsächlich Menschen assimilieren können, das andere
Ding, das ist  de Was in Europa
passiert, worüber die Leute nicht so viel reden, ist, dass die Offenheit für Einwanderung
große Teile Europas und Osteuropas entvölkert hat.
Wenn Sie sich also
Serbien, Rumänien in der Ukraine ansehen
, wissen Sie, dass Bulgarien
diese Länder entvölkert hat  Sie haben
in der letzten Generation manchmal 20 bis 30 Prozent ihrer Bevölkerung verloren,
und oft sind
dies entweder die am besten ausgebildeten,
ehrgeizigen Leute,
die nach London gezogen sind, oder Sie wissen schon, Hamburger oder
wo auch immer, und so bin ich  Ich bin mir nicht sicher, ob Sie
entweder für die Entsendeländer oder
für die Aufnahmeländer wissen, dass Sie
politisch ein völlig offenes
Einwanderungssystem kennen. Sie wissen wirklich, dass
Avast sich am besten daran erinnert, dass Hashem in dieser
außenstehenden Frau der Küste gedankt und
wahrscheinlich Demenz gelehrt hat, ein weltweit synchronisiertes
Problem  eine McCarthy-eigene Anspruchsavantika
Teresa, die ein Amish-Team entwickelt hat
und auf Anhieb sogar Indies außerhalb von
Vida spielte, damit wir ein paar Nüsse konnten und ich
anfangen würde  Reinigungsstock und das ist heute ein
australischer Vokal, wie ich sagte,
ich denke, das ist eigentlich ein grundlegendes
demokratisches Prinzip, also basiert eine Demokratie
auf der Souveränität des Volkes,
und das Schwierige ist, wer
die Leute sind, von denen Sie wissen, dass Sie
sprechen  darüber, und deshalb denke ich, dass man
tatsächlich in der Lage sein muss, Grenzen zu kontrollieren,
denn wenn man kein
Volk haben kann, das bekanntlich von
anderen nationalen Gruppen abgesetzt ist, das der Ort
der politischen Macht in der Gesellschaft ist,
kann man eigentlich keine Demokratie haben  Ich denke,
es ist tatsächlich entscheidend, um
die Möglichkeit der Demokratie überhaupt aufrechtzuerhalten
, und deshalb glaube
ich, dass Sie wissen, dass Sie Sympathie für
Migranten für Flüchtlinge haben können. Ich denke, dass
es eine moralische Verpflichtung gibt, sich um
so viele Menschen wie möglich zu kümmern, aber es ist so
Es ist einfach nicht eine unbegrenzte
Verantwortung. Meine Art der Freude an der
EU war eine endemische Kunst. Das Desha Institute
bald für einen Anti-Müdigkeits-
Gurt in Amerika. Beginnen Sie in diesem Jahr mit der
Organisation  Das Essen von Erbrochenem, das sie
kennen, Karte zum Unterschreiben, Fliegen weg und gerülpst,
ist gut. Ich meine, das ist die
Vision, aber ich denke, das Problem in
der EU ist, dass Sie das
Prinzip des offenen Reisens, das Sie kennen, innerhalb
der Schengen-Zone nicht frei haben können  Reisen ohne
Visa und Pässe Wenn Sie tatsächlich
keine gesicherten Außengrenzen haben und
wissen, dass Sie das eine oder andere haben können,
können Sie entweder innerhalb
der Zone eingeschränkt reisen und die Grenzen nach außen öffnen,
oder Sie können innerhalb der Zone frei reisen,
aber  Außengrenzen zu sichern,
und jetzt wissen Sie, dass
sie daran gearbeitet haben, die Außengrenzen zu sichern,
aber Sie wissen, dass sie
einen enormen Druck auf Italien
und Griechenland ausüben, die jetzt die wichtigsten
Kanäle für Menschen sind, die versuchen zu kommen
in Europa und ich glaube nicht, dass das eine
nachhaltige Situation ist, also yeah yeah düster
nach dir globales Problem II intra Seon
nach global und Handwerk, wenn ich Miss
Erin Politikerin unsere Umfrage Musiker und
unterwürfige
uns gehört habe  essen, wen schnappen sie ist Beatrice arbeitet, um zu
bedeuten, das Neueste in ihnen ist nicht zu sehen,
Tommy, harter Politiker, marktfähig,
Jota,
ich weiß, Yokota schaffen effizient, du weißt
sowieso, einige Frauen, es sind die Griffschichten,
es mm-hmm, also denke ich, dass
es eine große Veränderung gegeben hat  in der öffentlichen
Einstellung gegenüber China, die weitgehend
das Ergebnis des chinesischen Verhaltens sowohl in
Europa als auch in den Vereinigten Staaten ist, war die
Geschäftswelt früher der
größte Verfechter herzlicher,
voneinander abhängiger Wirtschaftsbeziehungen
zwischen dem Westen und China, und das hat
sich in den letzten Jahren völlig geändert,
weil  Ich denke, die Chinesen haben sich
nicht an die Regeln des
internationalen Handelssystems gehalten, wenn es darum geht
, geistiges Eigentum zu stehlen, ihnen keinen
gegenseitigen Zugang zu ihren
Märkten zu gewähren und
ihnen Zugang zu westlichen Märkten zu verschaffen,
und Sie wissen, dass Sie jetzt einen Anführer haben, Xi
Jinping in China, das eine
große Industriepolitik zur Subventionierung von
chinesischen Hightech-Industrien angekündigt hat
nicht mit dem
globalen System eines regelbasierten Wirtschaftssystems vereinbar ist
, und daher denke ich, dass es unvermeidlich sein wird,
dass es zu erhöhten
Spannungen kommen wird, außerdem ist die chinesische
Außenpolitik seit etwa 2008
viel aggressiver geworden, und das ist sie auch
diese Inseln im Südchinesischen Meer militarisiert hat
keiner von Chinas Nachbarn zugestimmt, dass
ihnen das Südchinesische Meer gehört, aber
Sie wissen, dass das ihre
Behauptung war, also denke ich, dass Sie wissen, dass
ich meine, ich gebe China nicht die Schuld in dem Sinne,
dass es  Sie wissen, Länder verhalten sich
so, wenn sie mächtiger werden, sie
beginnen, ihre Ausstellung zu erweitern, und
sie werden aggressiver, aber
das bedeutet nicht, dass Sie sich nicht dagegen wehren müssen
, also denke ich,
dass der Gesamtkonflikt mit  China wird
sich im Laufe der Zeit vertiefen, wenn ein
Visconti-Designer, der scharf auf Streik ist,
diese Anstrengung tut, als ein Politikermodell,
das alle mit Makati namens
Jeansshorts ausgestattet ist,
kapitalistische Mousse, die wir haben werden
Um das zu sehen, denke ich, dass
das China-Modell viele Schwächen hat, zum
Beispiel basierte das China-Modell darauf,
in den letzten 10 Jahren riesige Schuldenmengen anzuhäufen, so dass die
chinesische Verschuldung, die Sie kennen, eine
der höchsten überhaupt ist  Ländern der
Welt können sie das nur so lange am Laufen halten,
und ich denke, an einem bestimmten Punkt wird dieser
Wachstumsmotor
ausfallen, wenn das passiert. Ich
denke, es ist sehr schwer vorherzusagen, aber das ist
mir nicht klar  China wird
weiterhin ein ebenso erfolgreicher
wirtschaftlicher Akteur sein. Ich denke, sie haben
auch Probleme, weil ich nicht glaube, dass
sie eine intrinsische Quelle der
Legitimität haben, wie eine Demokratie im
Westen eine Legitimität hätte, die darauf basiert
Sein Festhalten an demokratischen Grundsätzen
und damit sowohl politisch als auch wirtschaftlich
China könnte in Zukunft in Schwierigkeiten geraten, wenn
er Thunfisch FOSDEM ND verachtet mich vermisse
Winter Ian Seal würde sogar in Stanford
im Silicon Valley eine Boutique Olsen
eröffnen  dass Zukunft
und wir erwischt haben, dass Fisch schmilzt,
Motormaschine informieren, wenn Stallführer der Zooarzt ist,
da er nicht erwähnt,
in wem diese violette Yaranzo Vivia ist,
da gib sie mir, also denke ich, dass sich
diese Utopie im Silicon Valley tatsächlich
in eine Art verwandelt hat  Alptraum
der letzten Jahre Ich denke, dass die
Vorteile der Informationstechnologie und
des Internets für die Demokratie
bereits in den 1990er Jahren, als das
Internet begann, allgemein akzeptiert wurden, aber ich denke, mit
den Wahlen im Jahr 2016 und der russischen
Bewaffnung des Internets haben die
Chinesen die Fähigkeit dazu  ihr Internet zu kontrollieren
und ihre Gesellschaft abzuschotten Ich
denke, es ist sehr klar, dass das
Internet nicht unbedingt ein Freund der
Demokratie ist.
Außerdem werden mit dem Fortschritt der Automatisierung und der
künstlichen Intelligenz viele
Arbeitsplätze weggenommen  vor allem von
gering qualifizierten Arbeitern, und das ist einer
der Gründe, die den Populismus und
diese wachsende Wut gegen die Eliten und mich antreiben
Ich denke, das sind Trends, die sich
leider fortsetzen werden. Ich
möchte wirklich nicht viele
Vorhersagen machen, wissen Sie, weil es sehr
schwer zu wissen ist, wie
Technologie Sie in Zukunft wirklich voranbringen wird,
aber ich denke, wir haben eine Reihe  von
Herausforderungen für uns, das ist sauber garniert
Holeczek auf severac Todd Hoffmans
allgemeines Gefühl, das auf
sie zukommt, denn dies alles ist in
etwas verpackt, wofür von Francis
Fukuyama vielen Dank
[Musik]
Ihnen